[Music]
oh hey there folks welcome to the lobby
I'm your host Chris Waters Eric is on
the couch some other guys here too and
we've got a great show for you here uh
today we've got uh counter spy coming up
a little later John and David are here
from Dynam Mighty and we're giving away
some codes for that game on the PS4 so
that's coming up in a bit Metro Redux
with Kevin vanord talking about
bloodborne as well but the F4 mentioned
Eric Tay is here to show off his max
level Diablo I evil character thing Evil
Edition come on guys T is here to to you
know actually give back something to the
the workplace that he's basically spent
the past couple of days just playing
this goddamn sinking it way into Dia
Daniel DWI it's great to have you back
here buddy uh let's give the folks at
home a little explanation are you you're
on the couch oh I'm so jetl so jetl so
I'm keeping it together I'm going to
glue it together until uh you're you're
all good next week mixing it up there's
nothing nothing wrong mixing up yeah
I've spent for those who don't know I've
spent the past couple of weeks in Europe
uh the last of which was at Gamescom of
course Comm it up we I saw some yeah
that's where all the Communists go to
play video games
it's great everything there is equal and
it's wonderful though that since they
took down the iron carton that hasn't
stopped that conference from going from
strength to strength there's like
300,000 people turn up with that thing
it is absolutely insane and this is the
first year I didn't even go get to the
show floor at all we were so busy in the
the the sort of the business area the
nicely air cooled business area not
teaming with the hordes of humanity it's
insane how many people go there ask me
my favorite game was Danny what was your
favorite game at Gamescom you know that
Ori in the blind Forest game I was so
apathetic about that when I saw the E3
trailer I was like great it looks really
pretty it'll probably be a really like
mechanically basic game that's going to
rest on its like prettiness Prett game
is great pretty neat right really good
uh you're very Nimble and quick yes as
the main character which you kind of
you're sort of paired with ory who's
this big kind of hulking yeah creature
who so I when I first saw it at E3 it
wasn't like I was that sensation was not
one I associated with it totally but you
are like flitting through the forest
it's really and it looks hard as hell so
that you remember did you see the video
of the the water like exploding through
the tree and Orie or whatever the name
of the actual character is called I I
did not I don't know character video
game character person is like flying
around it looked like incredibly hard I
was like there's no way they did that
live and then the guy when we had our
presentation did it live and it was like
inches to death really good yeah so like
speed running really tricky levels it's
it's way different to what I thought it
was or in the blind Forest really good
Far Cry forest ride Too Far Cry 4 also
red yeah Gamescom highlights shoot Bears
I saw you throwing them them hearts or
meat chunks
and if there's no leopard or like animal
there they just spawn it somewhere you
just have a meat pouch at all times and
it's not like the Rocks making a rain
meat it's not like the Rocks where you
run out of them or where you can't you
can run out of them H but when you're
skinning people you're also getting the
meat and yeah like animals if you mean
skinning animals skn okay although Far
Cry 4 didn't did I skin the bear or Sean
SK skinned the bear and then he be no we
got the bear me and then th it and
another bear went for it which was kind
of [__] up uh but uh it like spawns
animals close to you if if there's no
animal close that would go for us and I
did it in a house and a [__] snow
leopard came out of some dude's house it
made no sense they all turned around
like what the oh but that sounds awesome
it was great that sounds really
enjoyable coming out this year I cannot
believe that do you think do you believe
it do you believe it's coming out this
year uh not going to see like 11 hour
delay play the delay game don't play
that ubisoft's if we don't speak it it
won't happen yeah look at what happened
to evolve for you I know oh yeah had to
bring that up Jed it well the two
assassins are probably coming at well
they can't push those back the
division's been push back so you know
it'll be the only first person game
mobisoft for putting that this year so
hopefully that's coming up later once
the uh super release glut begins this
fall uh we're not quite there yet but
Diablo 3 ultimate Evil Edition is out
today yes uh on PS4 PS3 Xbox 360 and
Xbox One yep or wait is it it's just
never mind yes all of those and you've
got it here and you're dressed in like a
real stylish purple get up is this
Saints Row four let me see it let me see
your dude oh you want to see my dude
oops WR one no come on give me the Glam
there it is yeah wow creepy I mean I
guess we'll get it out of the way like
one of the one of the cool things new
things that you can do is you can kind
of play dress up it's like one of the
things they kind of um I don't know if
you want to say borrow or what not from
Warcraft it's the same company though
that's okay said all right fine stole
whatever uh so let's say for example you
have your helmet right oops sure hel my
commander siphon yeah my commander
siphon you can go in and depending on
this is some of the stuff you get as you
train up so tiny but um you get
different options for like what you want
your commander siphon Dome to look like
yeah so as you find like legendaries and
new items and whatnot it'll add to your
portfolio of things that you can change
your your outfit to look I'm going to
make my guy look like Shredder now yes
uh so like yeah see Shredder oh yeah up
Shredder sweet yeah so go shred some
things all right I'm going to go sh some
things didn't they they get around that
in the wow thing because people who had
like the best epic gear some of it just
looked like absolute ass together so
they just let you kind of yeah I mean
the one of the cool things about that
though was there were certain items you
could you couldn't like just use on
anything else to make it more special
but anyways this is uh this is one of
the new elements in uh this version of
the Diablo game the of Agony Evil
Edition it's a bounty uh which is like a
little mini Quest within the world uh
you have an objective that you have to
fill or um complete I have to kill
bludgeon skull and kill 100 monsters I
hate that guyon skull if you guys notice
uh I have a little fuse thing in the
middle of the screen 33 kills 34 kills
41 kills 42 kills yeah so that's going
to keep going it's like one of the new
kind of I don't want to call it a carrot
on a stick but it's kind of fun it it
makes you try to keep killing things is
score multiplier yeah so it gives you
more exp yeah you just got 2.5 times the
experience is that do you do you find uh
now you've leveled in Diablo many times
over on the PC version especially do you
find that that Massacre uh mechanic is
helped you level a little faster uh it
definitely did in certain cases uh
because as you can see the the EXP
multiplier is pretty high uh there's
certain things that like a cursed chest
event or something like that where I've
gotten like 200 kills before uh and that
you know obviously will help you level
up faster I am trapped now uh but yeah I
think it's also like a little fun
mechanic that it's very constantly um
you know like just keep going do you
always plow through this many people in
these Bounty missions like I usually
like just cuz this not
regular Diablo I feel like you're not
usually up against that many lowlevel
characters right um I mean the density
has increased quite a bit since uh this
in this iteration yeah um but downies
generally have pretty good monster
density in terms of like how many
monsters you're fighting I think the
sometimes I feel like the harder the
difficulty you set in on the more
monsters there are I don't think that's
always the case I think it's actually
more area based but uh there's always a
lot of you know grunt kind of monsters
that you can kill to kind of extend your
multiplier um there's also another thing
so like there's these traps now if there
was stuff there which sadly there wasn't
uh there's another oh that guy is fine
no but it had to be this trap that's
part of the map um but yeah if there was
Monsters there you would get a trap
bonus which you don't actually get in PC
is another thing uh so there's all these
different little multipliers that you
get um on this console version that have
in PC uh that is Templar that's a one of
the followers that you get okay is that
Shay Patrick cormick sure okay little
Assassin's Creed Unity reference than
yeah I got you Danny that's one that's
like the first of your references I've
got today the rest of it has just been
hope Miss Dynamite doesn't turn up in
this goddamn video game folks just a
quick reminder right now uh if you have
any questions for Eric about the
ultimate Evil Edition of Diablo I go
ahead and tell them to us in the chat at
twitch.tv/ Gamespot or in the comments
at gamespot.com and I'll take a look at
them and send him his way I've already
got a few lined up that I'm going to ask
you in just a sec sure also want to
remind you folks that we are giving away
codes for counter spy a game you're
going to see demoed later in the show
all you need to do to be entered to win
is follow Gamespot on Twitter and
retweet the giveaway tweet that Gamespot
just tweeted twet said the word tweet a
bunch there yeah it's the key to uh the
the functioning of this new Society we
live in Eric Dole legs wants to know why
you're not playing a monk uh because you
know I figure you got to switch it up
every now and then also uh the last time
I was here on the lobby for the PC
version I played monk so you know give
the people something fresh to see you
want to show people that you have range
yeah yeah you can diversify exactly
speaking of which uh what's it like
playing on the controller as opposed to
mouse and keyboard says Danny echoing
Red Hat Drew's question as well as hyper
flood's question yo that guy likes Linux
I will say I was very skeptical the
first time I played on Console even when
uh Diablo II came out on Console but I
have to say it's actually quite fun it
works out better than you think it would
uh it's hard for me to explain that
because it's like you have to try it
yourself but it's actually very fluid it
plays very well I was telling Chris
before we started cuz he was like hey do
you think you would play this over PC
and I was like well I probably wouldn't
play it over PC but if I didn't play PC
and I had a lot of friends that were
playing on Console just cuz they want to
play on Console this is a great game do
you play differently at all like do you
approach it differently like um was
there anything that you thought would be
more more challenging on a controller
that's that's
not not really so there's this other
mechanic too that's in the game there's
this like little role here yeah uh this
is not on PC it's supposed to help you
maneuver certain things because you know
Mouse is obviously more precise can
click where you want um this kind of
just you know you can roll the way you
want to the thing is for me like playing
a Demon Hunter like he has a skill that
can kind of evade already so since
that's better I'm not using the roll but
I could see melee classes using the roll
more often because it's like oh there's
you know freezing pulse on the ground or
something you want to get away from it
that's a fast way instead of just kind
of like Panic running away about like
ranged like you're trying to catch up
with dudes when you're trying to keep
that multiplier up right yeah exactly uh
sorry what was your question sorry what
about like ranged AOE stuff where you're
like trying to like do some AOE in the
back in the distance uh you can do that
I think that the screen is a little bit
more like limited than PC like I think
if I was doing that on PC and cuz it's
zoomed out more on PC it might actually
hit stuff further away so on this it's
got to at least be on the edge of the
screen I feel like um for it to actually
hit like within that corner of the
screen um but yeah so let me I'm not
really following to find the butcher
since I'm talking that's all right but
uh I'm going to show you what you would
get if uh you finish the bounties um
oops did you get some one of these uh
currencies for the like Nephilim Rift
yeah so you get Rift keystones as you
finish each uh Bounty and then if you
finish a whole axe Bounty uh you get a
reward which is whoops still terrible
with these controls what's the menu
like um I would say it's it's a little
weird for me at first because coming
from PC it's like okay I is inventory or
as my character whereas like this is
like pressing the touchpad and then like
but the start button is also for other
things so it's just kind of getting my
head wrapped up getting through all this
is all right yeah this is all right I
mean like this is the only thing like if
you were playing locally that would kind
of slow you down is like if I wanted to
change an item or a skill or something
like that which happens from time to
time uh I would have to pause you wouldd
have to wait I don't think it's like
that when you're playing online uh but
they do have like a quick inventory kind
of like like a quick shortcut way the
only thing is you can't tell you can see
that like cycling just above on the
right on the left side of the screen
just above all the his like health bars
yeah so uh I think these are just the
items that I have in my inventory that I
could switch to uh it's harder to tell
like two two Shields means like you're
getting more life or resistance you
don't actually get to see what it is
until you go into your inventory um but
yeah so anyways this is what you would
get from uh if you finish it oh I'll
tell you about that gift thing too so
you get a heric cash sorry oh man um and
it drops a bunch bu of things there are
that Templar stealing all your stuff no
that's me uh but those Bounty bags can
have act specific loot uh legendaries
that you can actually get which are
really good certain acts have like
really good ones like act one has a ring
that's like really good yeah pretty much
um it's actually it's actually like it's
a gamechanging ring man like how does it
change the game to like put that bling
on because what it is is that that ring
helps you get your set bonuses easier it
takes away like the requirement of like
one extra thing so like if to get like a
threeie b four of yeah to get the five
piece bonus you could still have the
four out of five and you get that so
then you get the rift Keystone
currencies which then you put into this
obisk Nephilim obisk sorry and it lets
you go into a Nephilim Rift which is
another kind of new thing this is what
they added to the PC one a couple months
ago Eric go deep into the lore what is a
Nephilim it's a so it's like an Oculus
Rift but it's it's like a different
company they're they're doing a kind of
a cheap version of it yeah um but in
this game uh it's if I remember the
story right it's like a a Nephilim Jesus
is that stitches no it's it looks like
stitches what's who's stitches stitches
is the [__] dude from duskwood in
World of Warcraft who just roamed over
he was an Elise that you did not mess
with on the path stitches is in Heroes
of the Storm though as a mobile well
he's from Warcraft right yeah yeah or
his peep his type or from or what are
they called again a bombs they're
Abominations Abominations yeah yeah hey
bombs but I think the the lore behind
the Nephilim or the like which is who
you are is like your powerful being I
believe that is like descended upon like
a descended from like the angels and
whatnot like uh definitely so you're
supposed to have you know be more
powerful than a human uh you
specifically and so you're able to go
into the Nephilim Rift and get uh
basically the P it's just they're more
challenging is that the idea uh the
nephron Rifts what they're supposed to
be are kind of like random randomized
dungeon that has you know like different
areas with different Monsters uh which
is something that's not in that wasn't
part of the game cuz it's was all stored
it's like monsters that wouldn't have
necessarily been in one area it's like
totally randomized right yep so this
just gives people a way to like match
the H Abomination you know go go to
different levels oh I got legendary
sweet oh no it's a recipe that sucks
that's literally you went from one end
to spectum to other yeah well I mean
like it's good for later so it's
emotional experience Diablo I ultimate
Evil is there anything like you're
playing this you know because you're a
massive fan is there anything in this
that if there are Folks at home were
playing this on PC that they should feel
compelled to get in on this um it's hard
to say like I said if you're hardcore
into PC you're probably not playing this
and I think blizzard knows that cuz
they've they've come out and said plenty
of times that they they feel like this
market like the console Market is for
you know different than their PC market
um like I said diabl games on consoles
before uh yeah you're right two was on
PlayStation 2 right uh was it I think
Diablo 1 was on PlayStation one and then
like they didn't do it for Diablo I I oh
really but what about that couch Co-op
couch Co-op is fun I mean I remember
when when when we first got Diablo II in
the office uh when Carolyn was playing
and and the rest of them they were
having more fun than they thought they
would yeah and I think couch Co-op is a
like you said it's like a it's a very
fun kind of thing and Hyper flood wants
to know does it like is there Slowdown
or does it still run very smoothly when
you've got more players on screen it's
fine I think they they've tuned the game
to you know respond properly for uh you
know four people even if you have a
bunch of skills going on at the same
time I think that's another reason why
they actually only limited it to four
people it used to be eight in Diablo I
but I think there's so much stuff on the
screen W it seems excessive well it was
also a complaint by people that there
wasn't eight but there's so much stuff
happening on the screen that I could see
why they couldn't have eight um people
yeah so it's four couch Co op you can
play online co-op uh you can do all
sorts of character transfer stuff if you
folks want to know more about Diablo I
ultimate Evil Edition we did an hour
live stream with two Diablo developers
on the game and they delved into like
all sorts of stuff to do with the uh
transfer of the game from PC to consoles
what kind of content you're getting in
what kind of uh obstacles they had to
overcome to put it on Console what kind
of adjustments they've made and how
Co-op Works in online connectivity and
importing your character the whole
shebang uh but Eric Tay Diablo 3
ultimate Evil Edition thanks for coming
on showing it off yeah thank you for
having me he's right as well didn't come
out on PlayStation 2 Diablo I hey man he
knows it all I got it he's got it down
fact finding thanks Danny way to own up
to it thank you all right folks uh we'll
be back in a minute with Kevin vort and
talking about bloodborne a game that
made a big splash at Gamescom and then
Metro Redux but first we're going to
take a look at a quick trailer for GTA 5
there's some new stuff coming to the
world of Los Santos let's take a
look at x-ray Runway 7
Runway 2 Runway
7 out here is where America's Heroes
play and you can too hi I'm JT Boyd
retired Marine leadership performance
coach and reenactment Enthusiast now you
can take America's tax dollars out for a
test drive at the San Andreas flight
school if you've always wanted to pay to
enjoy the thrill and exhilaration of
being a patriotic hero without having to
put in real time and effort the San
Andreas flight school is for you put the
life back into your midlife crisis like
any sensible new father learn the art of
hot dogging in our new Jets or Swift
helicopter or demonstrate your continued
manliness with a road race master air
and land superiority and then fly the
flag of your country on our new
patriotically themed parachute
bags it's a fact women love men in
uniform who shower with other men and
look Moody while riding motorcycles
woohoo look at that come be part of the
Montage the San Andreas flight school
the best of the
[Music]
[Applause]
best Los Santos baby still happening
what do you guys think new GTA stuff Rob
Handler you're probably taking a look at
it yeah I am I uh just finished
installing in it I can't wait to get
into it it looks great all right so
probably later this week you'll hear the
Rob report on new GTA uh stuff Kevin
vanord you're on the couch now he yo hi
welcome uh guys we're going to talk
about bloodborne in a second okay we're
going to talk about bloodborne now okay
so uh they showed a bunch of new
gameplay footage at Gamescom uh we want
to take a look at it again because it
looks really good uh what do you guys
think what do you guys make of this game
you know uh well I mean Dark Souls I
mean that's Dark Souls is my favorite
game of the generation we have just
climbed out of and we've clawed our way
free of the PlayStation 3 and Xbox 3 no
we haven't we're still there but you
know look it's true but you know what I
mean you know what I mean and I see and
I see some comments on the on the video
and on the on on the on the stuff saying
you know it's just Dark Souls blah blah
blah and I don't I don't know that that
necessar has to be a a bad thing you
know uh so I I I really like the way it
looks I really love the art style I mean
it doesn't when I look at it it looks
like okay so it plays a little bit like
you know somewhat like Dark Souls it
uses some of the same basic mechanics
but this world doesn't really look like
it feels like dark souls and that's a
big part of the Dark Souls experience is
the feel so now you've got bloodborne
and it looks like this Victorian era You
Know Jack the Ripper type atmosphere
you're talking specifically about the
environmental design cuz I look at this
and it looks like the movement it looks
like you know the the UI like it the
enemies sort of the the spacing the
lighting it feels very much like a dark
souls and it's from you know from
software is one of the developers on it
I think they're working with another
team that is escaping my brainium right
now but you're right this is not a world
like this is a very distinct environment
yeah they showed you know crowds of like
um enemies walking around they seem to
be doing like their own thing like I
mean I I actually never played really
dark souls but if there's anything I
would say about that is bosses seem
pretty I don't know generic a little bit
as comp like compared to like bosses
here where you know they're they're
moving around they're you know well I
guess we're like three into the so
series as it were so you know it's I
guess the the thing that will always pop
out is the change of environment have
they touch touched on like how much
technology is going to play a part here
because obviously like weapons like guns
range weapons that like changes up the
combat quite a lot we're seeing a lot of
hand onand here or like Melee
fighting have they talked or have you
have you seen anything Kevin that like
makes it look different in terms of well
they they talked about um how how you're
going to replenish Health if you're more
aggressive like if you really get in
there and start chopping up enemies um
in in in combo land then you're going to
you're going to be able to start like
earning Health by doing that and I think
that the intention is to is to uh get
you to focus on a on a more aggressive
style of play than maybe Dark Souls
would offer that will be interesting for
me cuz my dark because as a you know I
go into Dark Souls stamina heavy like
I'm all about taking as many hits as I
can before I can get in my own you know
my own chance so I'm kind of curious you
want to be able to block yeah so I'm
curious is this going to is this going
to have me a little more active is this
going to have me having to be a little
more agile um I don't know but then you
look at stuff like that it's like oh he
rolls the same way oh he you know he he
moves the same way attacks the same way
cloth moves the same way so and of
course I look at that bit there's a bit
where where he picks up the torch in the
darkness and and uh it looks like oh you
need the torch for the darkness but we
heard that already about Dark Souls 2
and that didn't really come to fruition
look at that dude but the enemy design
is so good are they going to have guns
as well I hope enemies what do you have
gun Rock to just like a a
brick this guy has when you're that when
you're as big as that dude all you need
is a brick all you need is a brick grab
his
junk knocked him on his butt we can only
hope when's this bad boy at again
sometime 2015 so that's an interesting
move too the leap in and the jump Kevin
doesn't care oh right yeah 201 I'm sorry
I'm I'm watching the footage I'm
watching the
footage oh yeah the old the old giant
axe Spin Attack so yeah uh certainly you
know creature design always the strength
of the Dark Souls or of the souls series
that seems to be represented here genre
now right it really is well I mean I
feel like we have to have a few more
imitators but I don't know we had one of
we have ators now wet you put wet in
there as well wet wet yeah that is
definitely the most soulan game Sorry we
just haven't talked about I don't
mention that game in well we've got that
other game that looks very saly coming
up and now I suddenly forgot the name of
it uh it's called wet to no blade
something wet harder um somebody out
there knows what I'm talking about I
suddenly forgotten the name of not wet
not blade but it's not wet I am looking
forward to hellblade though because
Ninja Theory thumbs up I'm looking
forward to them renaming that Heavenly
sword too
they've come right out and said it's
notedly no that's
actually I like the fact that they're
not lying they're not resting on their
their old highp for a little bit of
marketing hype all right that's a look
at bloodborne in action folks uh Now
Kevin get get yourself into some Metro
Redux let's talk about rum and Friends
uh rob you look like you're holding the
controller I am are you going to drive
us here into the uh
posted because they redid it red redo
it's like Apocalypse Now isn't isn't
that a cooking thing where you like cook
stuff down and you like drizzle some
redo on top of it you make a rue there
you go AED a redo it's a r what am I
talking about nobody's nobody's here to
listen so Metro Redux is Metro 2033 and
Metro together in one Xbox One
PlayStation 4 package PC package as well
um yes as a matter of fact yes and
one of the most important things is the
way Metro 2033 has been improved
visually and brought sort of up to the
Metro last Light level um so now
2033 has the Metro last Light interface
it now includes the the same weapon
craft thing and there's there's some
interesting stuff too where you can sort
of play Last Light more in the style of
2033 in the sense that uh it will it
will sort of reduce the amount of ammo
exactly
redo the ammo and and gas masks and so
on and sort of tweak The Experience so
it feels more like a 23 2033 experience
in which you have to it feels a little
bit more uh scant the resources you a
little bit more scary a little bit more
like survival horror might feel like but
then if but then you also can apply the
sort of the last Light a little bit more
gung-ho aspect to Metro 2033 so you can
play both games in a way that more or
less they can feel the same regardless
of whether you preferred sort of the
2033 style or whether you preferred the
last Light style but more interesting is
is is the visual upgrade to me at least
because now at least the first game yeah
at least with the first game well with
last Light you barely notice if you're
playing on PC for example you're not
getting a drastically different
different game in fact you're getting
essentially the same game last was just
out last year so you can't expect there
to be Leaps and Bounds that they're
going to be able to take for it but 2033
is a different story 2033 is definitely
a different story and if if you were to
play them back to back and when I played
them I you know having played 2033 and
last Light in the past I actually did
this thing where I was going back and
forth chapter to chapter to chapter to
chapter to chapter to chapter to sort of
look and see
how I like that moment I like this
moment when you go under underw and
you're like oh I blew it it's probably
really cold you guys have no idea how
cold that stinky Moscow water is I'm
going to guess it's pretty cold
considering there's lots of ice and snow
around um but and and I'm no expert on
weatherology that's true you do not have
your weatherology degree you've only
taken a few online courses yes but the
the the games do look you know and I
said this in the review and you should
go read the review but not now after
you're finished watching us of course
homor but you know I mentioned in the
review you know something I feel very
strongly about which is like instead of
it feeling like a game and sequel it now
feels more like you know sort of like a
walking deadish kind of thing where it's
like here's the game first part of the
game and now here's the second part of
the game
do they narratively kind of complement
each other that way like does does at
the end of 33 do you feel like last
Light picks up from it yes well last
Light does pick up directly from the EV
last have like a satisfying ending so um
it does uh 2033 has a good ending but
also there's a choice at the end of it
then it only ends up last Light only
starts one way so what choice you made
at the end of 2033 yeah the Canon
through line may be and I don't want to
give anything away of course but and
it's interesting last Light was my
favorite game last year so which which
always seems to surprise a lot of people
but uh I really like the upgrades to
2033 there are a couple things that I
miss um one is I feel like the the the
noses the which are one of which are
like the the creatures nois right got
blood I say
noal you say no soles the Russian dudes
in the game say no soles I'm I'm kidding
kidding oh okay so anyway so I like I in
some cases I like the way they look in
the first game a little bit more they're
they're a little bit more oh dark one
they're a little bit more furry and well
yeah Speedy a little buer but they're
they're furry and a little bit more
furry and they used to look a little bit
more creepy and alien weird naked mol
rat thing going on the first one yeah
they look they look a little bit more
honestly they look like they probably
belong more in this world than the
original design but the original design
had that sort of creepy alien look that
that freaked me out um and there are a
few other things like some of the gas
masks that 2033 has that gas mask that
has the they they they have the um the
the night vision goggles that are
attached that come down and I don't
remember seeing any of those in the in
the Redux version but you see those in
the um in the original 2033 and it's a
really interesting looking helmet and I
kind of missed that while I was playing
Redux cuz I don't remember seeing any
there
um but uh and of course some people just
like the the lighting is much improved
but some people kind of like that old
lighting because it was more high
contrast and and a little bit Faker
looking but they kind of liked the you
know but side by side like you can
really tell the difference you should
check out Rob's thing oh I guess you're
seeing it on the screen right
now that's really awesome you know thank
God they got that but this is really
interesting like here's the original and
then there's you can see the you know a
big difference you know presumably like
this was not just a real simple you know
texture of plate that they had this
completely redone in a lot of cases um
even even cutcenes like um you know
there there places so so in the in Metro
2033 the original like a lot of cut
scenes took place and showed you um arum
in the in the third person and now
everything takes place in first person
to keep it um more in line with how they
did Metro last Light so another thing
they did we talked about this was how
they they seem to have changed a lot of
voice voice over as well a lot of voice
over and that that end up really
bothering me we we had this discussion
yesterday about the the bit in 2033
where you come across a kid and you put
them on your shoulders and kind of take
him home through the thing so video game
children look freaky most of the time
anyway um and often like kind of sound
freaky too because they're adults
playing children adults playing children
but also like yeah the character model
and the way that it's like the
proportions are just they'll
have jaw and it's like you're 9 years
old this game is no exception but that
whole bit like you come across the kid
he doesn't look like a kid he looks like
a miniature adult he sounds like a
miniature adult when he talks and the
dialogue makes no sense because he's not
saying anything a child would actually
say yo you got a pack of
smokes I got to do my [__] taxes so
there there are there are bits like that
my wife's breaking my ball
kind I got
kids there are bits like that that kind
of stand out um and they stood out
before but now they stand out even more
because uh just jump down yeah there you
go well yeah and what's so funny is like
it's clearly a you know a woman you know
pretending to be a boy like Bart effect
but you know she at least pulls it off
Nancy cartright actually sounds like a
boy like Bob's Burgers OE and Andy are
are you know the Silverman sisters but
literally it sounds like they sound like
four hey mister like come on over here I
know the way he's got this oversized
coat on his and his fantastic Russian
accent that you just showed off thank
you oh you're I had to do the hands hey
M he's over ja follow me I'm a kid you
know it's me a child unbelievable child
New Jersey Oliver
Twist so there yes I are we talking
about a game I forgot exactly what we're
doing I think we're reenacting I just
want to see this [__] up kid now
that's all I want to see I don't think
we're going to I don't think we're going
to get there in this it's it's quite a
bit ahead of this um is this where some
playing for someone who we could we
could actually do it do you I think we
could do it on Xbox one I mean we want
to check out this new menu I think it
looks great we just watch that for like
two
minutes loading that here's here's and I
didn't mention this in the review but
you know one of those little things that
kind of bothers me as you go through is
that you find
um diary pages that you pick up now in
most games you're picking up other
people's like remnants in and here
you're picking up your own things and so
it it doesn't make any sense like what
did you do go to all these places
beforehand and spread your own diary
around and then you're going through
also why would you be picking your diary
it's like why are you know what's in it
you're learning oh that's you're
learning from your own words this
doesn't make any sense aren't you
picking up a piece of paper and then
maybe taking a moment to do a diary
entry is that what it is like I found I
like found some paper in a quiet moment
I'm going to like record some of my
thought that's not like how the game
presented it's just like you you just
pick up a a dossier right there and pick
it up it's like oh so here's what I was
thinking if all if I hadn't read this I
would never have known the contents of
my own brain but other other like
obviously I think both I think 2033 is
quite good and I think blast light is
really really excellent remains
excellent we're having some fun at the
game's expense but I think this is one
of those situations where like you know
there's a few weird things that sort of
stand out to you are fun to talk about
but like overall these are excellent
games and this is like a really great
way to to play them oh totally and one
of the one thing I like about it now I
like you know and we had kind of a
difference of opinion in terms of like
the pervading darkness and whether that
works to the to the game's advantage or
not but but but I really like and and
this comes as no surprise to anybody
that knows how much I love Dark Souls
but I I love this kind of atmosphere
anyway but one of the things I really
love is that it's not cheesy here it's
not I mean you spend a lot of time
simply existing in these places and when
people talk and these guys have these
Russian accents they kind of sound you
know they're always looking a little bit
they're always telling like little jokes
are always just trying to get a little
bit of humor in there and it and it
feels like okay These Guys these are
guys who have lost hope but um you know
a little bit of vodka a little bit of uh
a little bit of making fun of things and
you know maybe they found a reason to to
to push through this yeah they've got
this like this flinty humor of that's
like you know they there's a defeated
heir to them but they're still just like
well that's my world live in it you know
let's go on and see what's going so what
do you think about that girl over there
huh you know and and of and of course
boobs so if you're into that there's
there's some boobs is there new HD boobs
are the boobs reded it's really no
straight up they are like I remember
playing scene I playing the scene and
then there's this girl walks by and
you're like oh she's got big ones huh
and then you do the Redux and you see it
and it's like she even looks at you oh
no they like hand completely redone I'm
surprised you didn't put that in the
graphics comparison just WIP back and
forth across that a few times thank you
for your restraint rob it it's really
yeah the game does this whole world has
sort of a a really interesting way women
don't
um have much more um to do in this in
this world they're not the tunnels
they're just kind of sitting stationary
in the cities where you can interact
with them a little bit making weird
adies um you know strong woman um in in
last Light but it's it's not a a role
that is is really fleshed out or even
accompanies you for long instead you
just hang out with a guy named bourbon
bourbon bourbon is fun I think bourbon
is really fun is it bourbon like the
like the drink or like the chocolate
biscuits no it's like the drink all
right it's like the drink what chocol
get that reference either that's Danny I
I have no idea what you're talking about
I don't understand Irish biscuits
everything I know about uh Irish people
I learned from the Assassin's Creed
trailer great so yeah sh sha ACC legit
sha Patrick Connor whatever his name is
it's not Conor Shri what is it it is
corm Cormac yeah he's got three first
names that's like calling somebody like
an American character Billy Joe Bob or
something make any sense how far away
from this weird kid are we rob don't St
the
thing Jesus Christ wow oh he died yeah
he was showing you and everything and
you're like blah blah blah blah Irish
people it wasn't my fault that he
[__] killed his friend that's true
that was Rob's fault he just he just ran
straight through the trip wire yeah oh
well oh well don't do that to see the
weird kid why don't you get Metro last
Light Redo for yourself that's
right like I don't know where it is I
can't find it but there is there is the
creepy moment with the kid and the kid's
all creepy don't say the creepy moment
with the kid Kevin but then you I'll say
that so it's Metro you fall down the
holes Xbox One PS4 PC 50
bucks 50 bucks it's 50 bucks yes yes
it's 50 bucks sorry now next week like
we get it a week early we get to talk
about it like yeah we get to talk about
it like a whole week early great job
cool like so good for us we get to play
you don't right now W took a turn there
Kevin yeah thank thank you for coming on
anyway I like to Lord it over
others thank you rob thanks for uh nobly
trying to get us to see a weird kid but
instead just K yourbody oh well you're a
weird kid so we got to see you D there
you go can you can you do the whole can
you do the thing again like the Boston
kid uhoh one more time I knows the way
just give me a couple blocks I'll shows
you guys smokes nah not for me for my
dad just kidding for me we have to toss
to a Destiny trailer why don't your oh
okay yeah go ahead in that voice so up
next we got a Destiny trailer stay tuned
no we've over egged it over egged it
we're try hards
[Music]
now
[Applause]
oh
it doesn't matter who you were only what
you will
[Music]
become there's three Europe that is like
just three weeks away I am very excited
for it all right well please join me in
welcoming to the couch uh Dave and John
from Dynam Mighty guys welcome to the
show glad to have you here uh counter
spy it's a game that folks on gam spot
have gotten some a few looks at before
but it's out today also we're giving
some of them away uh so if you want to
go ahead and retweet games spots tweet
about the giveaway and follow Gamespot
you can win some counter spy codes you
guys generously provided uh but dude
your your game's out today h all right
how are you even like controlling
yourself enough to sit still on the
couch this must be so exciting for you
it's such a great feeling I mean we've
been working so hard on this for over a
year and a half now and so finally to
get it out and put it in front of people
and let get some feedback from what
people think about it it's just such a
great feeling you know a little bit of
relief but also a lot of excitement a
lot of excitement and so we're playing
on PS4 now and but you guys are also on
PS3 and PS Vita yep that's correct uh
it's Cross by and it has cross save uh
cross save capability music to my ears
absolutely do you guys get like Dan you
get excited as when you hear that cuz
it's it's it's like a deal breaker
sometimes yeah completely I'm really
lazy it's it's not it's like when it's
like when I hear that it's got cross
saave I'm like okay yeah I'm in it's
like cuz my TV is like 10t away from my
bed but that 10 ft is a big difference
when it comes to like like just wanting
to be in bed and doing it on the V so
yeah yeah nice work putting in that
extra that extra effort cuz not enough
people do it very cool it's the best you
just have to have TVs throughout your
entire house
and you can do it that way as well right
I tried to do that g those dark old days
think of all the counter space you can
free up in wall space counter space for
counter spy counter space for counter
spy all right so uh we're playing as uh
a spy in the counter organization I
don't know if we have a camera angle
that can check the the wall art in the
back you guys added on but uh it's on
there we we'll get it get a look at it
uh but this is you guys are you guys
really leaned into and are big fans of
that sort of' 60s 7s cold War era and
that and this this stuff almost looks
like propaganda art a little bit like
well um yeah we kind of uh I guess one
way that we've described it before is
it's sort of um a little bit of our love
letter of to The Incredibles mixed in uh
with a little bit of bond and kind of a
dash of Doctor Strange Love um and the
propaganda angle is I guess something
that um so Mark who's our art director
um really brought to it he went crazy on
like when you go throughout the levels
you'll see all these sort of posters and
all the design around the world um and
because we kind of focus this on you're
you're you're going into both
superpowers right like you're not uh um
a us or a Soviet agent um or in our
world the the superpowers are the
imperialists and the Socialist right um
and so you're this sort of Rogue agency
that's breaking into both of them which
one is the
socialists well what do you think we
could have a long discussion about that
yeah actually we could get real deep ons
geopolitical stuff here uh but I'm not I
I can't read Russian does this actually
say stuff in Russian or you guys just
make like it is Russian okay it is
Russian you don't know the is that what
you're tell me gole translate tells us
it's Russian excent I'll just get yeah
hold up my phone to it get some
translation going it'll be good would
you refer to this video game as a 2.5d
game is that fair or is that super
reductive um yeah sure two 2 and 1 half
D I guess um I think what does it mean
cuz that's what made it to me the first
time I saw it was was seeing all this
stuff well I think that the thing that
we kind of got excited about was um so
the inspiration is very much our our
love for sort of classic arcade style
Sid scrollers right um but because we're
building it out in 3D uh we kind of
realized that we could open up the
combat space a little bit more and have
these cover points um you pop into cover
and the camera shifts around so yeah I
think that to your point about the 2 and
1 half D I guess that's a a good way of
describing it that's something a games
journalist would say I suppose exactly
perfect we'll go with it yeah I mean we
just love the way that you know with 2D
side scrollers you can have a fairly
simple control scheme but then when you
can switch into the 3D camera like this
we can still set up pretty cool dramatic
angles like this and so you know you can
have sort of a little bit more of a kind
of almost cinematic type setup that but
you're not sitting there having to
control the camera yourself it's like
you know we do it for them basically
that is kind of a neat way of amplifying
that sort of cinematic uh appeal that
kind of you know the the dramatic angle
oh jeez nice awesome rag doll there
nice he's now just a permanent fixture
in this bunker exactly uh what's your
mission coming in here then cuz I notice
a lot of like collectible stuff in like
hidden areas and whatnot right yeah so
um because basically the both
superpowers are trying to uh launch
rockets at the Moon they're sort of in
this Race Against Time and you're trying
to stop them so throughout the game
you're you're looking for the launch
plans like that your your main goal is
collect all the launch plans so that you
can uh uncover one of the locations go
there sabotage the rocket uh but along
the way there's a lot of hidden areas to
explore and discover stuff um there's
things like blueprints that you collect
and that's how you'll uh complete your
um your you'll unlock weapons uh dossier
there's lots of little Collectibles um I
just actually also wanted to draw your
attention cuz John normally doesn't play
as well as this I was going to say two
head shot back to back he's actually if
you look in the top right of the corner
there's a stealth combo that he has
going that's actually a pretty cool
Advanced uh sort of way to play the game
so for people who are diving into the
game now um sort of earning currency in
the game particularly as it gets harder
like that becomes more and more
important
um you'll find Intel in the world and
things like that um but also um the
stealth combos will be a big points
multiplier the more people you can sort
of stealth kill in a row uh adds up to
more points and then you get more cash
at the end you kind of your agent Bonus
Goes Up oh nice there John uh is there
also like a do you guys have like a
leaderboard uh that sort of that also
services on yeah we've got uh
leaderboards um and we also have a kind
of a cool little feature where there's
this rival spy mode so uh once all your
friends are playing and you're seeing
their scores on the leaderboard the game
will start giving you um a friend score
for that level and uh as a Target and
then if you can beat their score and
sort of best it then on the next level
you can go find their agent and then
you'll get more points more cash good
but you can go find like their what find
their agent what do you mean by that so
basically uh you beat their score and
then on the next level um their agent is
hidden somewhere in the level their down
agent so if you can find their down
agent in the level you can kind of get
the Intel off of them and then you'll
get some extra cash oh interesting they
show up as a sort of an extra objective
yeah it's like instead of just chasing
your friend's leaderboard and going oh I
beat your score it's just a little extra
Easter egg where you can actually go out
um look around if you find the agent
then you'll you'll also get some extra
extra cash for your game I think this
might be my best I was about to say like
you're you can see you like just being
extra careful now as well fixed yeah so
I should say I'm like the engineer on
the team here and so I often end up
spending a lot more time kind of staring
at like some gnarly bug rather than
actually playing the game so it's kind
of fun to sit down here and dive in of
all days for you to excel John yeah
today is that day exactly when the
pressure is on huh uh so I guess sort of
the the way you're moving through the
levels it seems to be sort of uh you
know once you get to a to a certain you
know area this board this you know
between these two sets of doors do you
just kind of clear that area move on to
the next area and then progress that way
do you ever have to sort of backtrack or
anything like that no it's uh the the
John sort of playing in a methodical way
clearing the room and that is generally
a good way to play um the the levels are
all stitched together procedurally so
rooms get reordered in different ways so
if you started playing a game again you
wouldn't see the same levels um and so
generally you start out on the left and
then you're kind of moving in One
Direction um there are areas where there
there's a little bit of branching so
there's like elevators and you can go
down and there's sort of alternate paths
that'll lead you to extra stuff um and
there's also a lot of hidden areas but
um generally like the way that excuse me
John's playing right now he's also doing
a good job of managing the Defcon which
is the number that you see in the middle
of the Hub there which is currently at
three
so I think he noticed his friend's
head's missing he did John I can't
believe you might actually finish this
level I don't want
to ched it all right I was so close now
I can start having we might actually see
um one of the guys get on the radio but
basically um the defcom will go up uh
based on how much the enemy sees your
presence in the world right so if they
see you they might start getting on the
radio so there's a dude right now he's
radioing in that's causing the death Gom
to go up oh yeah see the meter security
cameras if they spot you that'll cause
the deathcon to go up um and also if you
die there's a penalty um and so that
defcom p uh level something you kind of
want to be managing throughout the game
and it also is consistent from level to
level so uh if it gets too high then
they start a countdown and they're going
to launch and that way you've just got
to book it to the end of the level oh
great and trying to Port the launch it's
only now I appreciate how difficult the
head shot are that you've been like
nailing them the entire time it's a
little tougher when they're throwing
bullets back you yeah yeah because it's
not a game about just sort of waiting in
I mean you're not you're not able to
take much damage that Defcon is going to
go up fairly Speedy but are you so but
here you completed the mission the meter
went down so even though it it does sort
of is a through line from mission to
Mission there is a way to to reset it a
little bit Yeah but if it went up to
like two and then to one like it won't
go back down oh I'm a bit croaky once it
hits the threshold and changes number it
won't re go back down from that number
it won't go back down but you can uh get
it to go down and one of this is where
one of the key uh strategies you need to
deploy in the game is uh officers in the
game they're pretty cowardly lot if you
see an officer hopefully we'll see one
in this next level yeah you should
definitely play an imperialist level um
yeah if you see an officer in the level
um um uh you should uh take out all his
friends so that he's all on his own and
then if you can aim your weapon at him
um he'll surrender and then he'll
actually call in and uh lower the death
everything's cool over here guys oh
we're fine y ship shape no need to be so
alarmed yeah so it's it's kind of a key
part of the game is is managing that
level and it's one of the things um at
one point we had just a straight
Countdown the whole time and you're sort
of running against the clock but it's
one of these things during game
development you're always trying
different things to see what works and
what doesn't we we kind of realized that
it it kind of took a lot of the fun of
the exploration out of the game and if
you're always worrying about that clock
going down you're not really going to
take your time to like wait for hide
wait for dude to come up and then you
know stealth kill him you're just going
to be running um and so this this sort
of really helped stretch that out it
still gives the player something to
manage and keep an eye on bit of
pressure right but then once that
countdown starts then you know okay now
I've got to kind of book it and get to
the end explosives are your friends
that's great you named one after me a
guys so sweet there you go when we go to
ig later we have a we have a special one
with like in there as well
yeah you guys know your audience here
easily pandered to uh I'm a little
worried you just went through that door
it said no spies through there um is
that going to be a problem what does
they're not really big fans of us so you
know what does ker stand for uh we might
run a competition and maybe people can
guess what it is that's our clever way
of saying we we did have um we knew what
it meant once did you lose a des we done
so many late nights on this game to get
it done that it's locked away in some
part of our brain somewhere yeah it
actually is on a document somewhere one
night you're just going to sit up in bed
at night and and just like recite the
entire so here's an officer he he
actually hasn't seen you so what you
should do John is switch to a noisy
weapon don't mess it up John and don't
shoot him don't shoot that Barrel it's
so tempting though oh
we any other situation I would always
say shoot the barrel so he spotted me
and then make him surrender and the
deathcon goes up there now shoot the
barrel all right all right I wonder if
this will no it won't will that put the
death back up he should probably get out
of there oh well no great we're you're
not allowed to take out surrendered
officers once they surr once they've
surrendered the Geneva Convention exists
in this game as well their lives are
over anyways you don't understand yeah
he's going to have to go back and report
to a superior Commander now so oh
there's a power all right all right
maybe I'll just get a bit more so aside
from like the you know from looking as
slick you know as John here you know
that's a that's a motivation for stealth
uh the point system stuff like that is
there uh you know you complete you you
you stay stealth you complete it you get
more money to help then like upgrade
your kit was that it come on John you're
not playing all right sorry I was
listening so yeah so you can basically
uh you go through you find blueprints
which will unlock new weapons uh you
find formulas which give you kind of
boosts like onetime boosts for uh for
that level um and then there's also
dossier which give you a bit of the sort
of backstory of the world of counter and
uh the two superpowers um and uh then as
you play through the levels you know
you're both trying to unlock those
things and collect cash which you know
once you've uh found all the blueprints
for a weapon you spend the money to buy
those new
weapons not just pistols all day no so
we've got a few kind of fun weapons that
you can upgrade as you go on through you
know sort of more powerful machine guns
um we have a mind control weapon that
gets the uh the enemies to kind of
attack each other and so mind control a
few other fun ones there that people can
find as they play through the game yeah
the the game it gets progressively
harder the further you go there's more
Elite guards you know take more damage
stuff like that so some of the earlier
weapons will lose a bit of their
effectiveness so something like the uh
the Mind Control gun is awesome cuz you
can take if you can get one of the the
really tough guys with that oh man oh
you killed the officer
Dave I don't know my chance you're
supposed to be better than me D thought
that's why you brought John along Dave
um if I'm trying to talk and play though
John so credit
here consult your multitasker John knows
I'm not a multitasker
so you should see he'll try and talk to
me when I'm working like are you what
did someone say something um what was I
saying I know but I like how it was
super interesting what Dave's kind of
going the other way here with a bit more
of a sort of aggressive play through and
so you know the game definitely supports
both the play Styles you know if you
just want to go in use the explosives
have a bit of fun you know are those the
hats coming off or their
faces it's the hats it's a tated game
all right okay but it's really the faces
right that's wishful thinking I think I
know we did have blood running down the
skin in the last game but you know this
one is definitely for the youngsters as
well um yeah what was it saying oh yeah
that mind control gun um yeah good
strategy for for later on um when you
get those tough guys that come out and
they're super hard to kill shoot one of
those guys with the Mind Control gun so
now he becomes a bullet sponge for his
friends they'll turn on each other and
then sometimes you can just sit back and
let them kind of enjoy the battle out
check your tweets real quick exactly hey
What's Going look up over all right
we're clear hey cool uh speaking of
tweets we have some winners Twitter uh
some Victors uh who are going to be
getting counter spy codes and I'm going
to ask uh one of you kind gentlemen if
you would mind reading out the four
names they guess the name of counter no
we didn't make it that hard for them but
uh here are the winners uh of counter
spy codes all right number one is hyper
flood all right hyper flood hyper flood
have fun uh number two is NM
rain making a rain what do you think NM
stands for need more need more rain
could be uh farmer X Matrix gaming yeah
sure sounds name of and the final one is
Alvin
Princessa congratulations each and every
one of you fantastic got for those it's
available today on the PlayStation Store
correct yeah exactly when's it out in
Europe uh it goes out yeah later on same
time tomorrow so probably like 3: 4 in
the afternoon cool European time I think
it just went live around now actually
PlayStation store so oh man y very cool
uh do you guys do you have any Platforms
in mind a PC release somewhere down the
way interesting you might ask so uh so
today it's available on PlayStation 4
PlayStation 3 and Vita MH uh but we do
have uh IOS and Android versions coming
all right so um those are it's not the
exact same game but it is interesting
because it has a lot of the same core
gameplay you're still an agent you're
sneaky through levels doing all your
sort of spy stuff so we're actually
pretty excited about that and it has
cross saave
yay everyone making games take a note
absolutely take a note out of these
gentleman's book cross sa on everything
so your progress is transferred across
like your actual levels you play through
are a different so you can't transfer
that part but all the uh the blueprints
you've unlocked and the formulas they
transfer across um and there's even if
you link it with your PlayStation you uh
you can find some extra kind of weapons
that you wouldn't be able to get onall
game by uh linking them together so more
and that's coming down on the way did
you say coming out in about two three
weeks we don't have an exact date
yet you're Dave oh good cool John hi
Dave John whichever one of you is which
who can even keep track I don't know
Chris uh thank you guys so much for
coming on showing off counter [__]
congratulations on the release big day
for you guys we to have a Bear yes a
well earned beer one or two uh Danny you
and I should get one too just you I have
a bottle of buck fast than underne my
desk I brought back from the UK where's
your desk cuz if you have to stay here
we'll we'll go they'll take care of that
for us take my buy away from we'll have
to deal with some real drunken angry
game developers in about four minutes
judging by what that stuff is like Buck
fast gets you I won't finish that thanks
Danny for your discretion and also
co-hosting no worries pleasure to be
back uh and thank you folks for tuning
in and watching the lobby today we're
back next week at 2 pm. with all sorts
of packs Prime Prep more new games and
exciting stuff please come back and join
us then see you later
bye Mary don't mess up the jip shot you
can do
itot this way this way a bit more this
[Music]
way